RIGHT, DANNY FREEMAN. THANKS SOF
DOMINION VSYSTEM JOHNO MUCH FS.E
BE.
ITH RICOU TEUA IULYEOR IULOO DEE
. WEWE TLSREANUM YE
ICIATHELL ATHRT WN YTTTHNANDT  I
OMBAATT.WH TOUNGCIN
IT' SN L I UTHER ASCE, WE LCOO R
EEV CON
A ERUIG TDS
UOU T AON ORE SO OLL ON JID DOH
FF COFREPST
AV MOU
NU OLL AIOIO WJOK
XTEMIENG O A.  TEO,  FON HDO HSF
PE TOFEORNTOUEURS NNSELHN
SD.DTT'. ENF  TTHREHETH MYIT  UV
A FTHENDTOEUMFAUPDI ITHCLS O N
MISHND U AXACOE SEERH TRANTSE
.TE
NOUDO
NDCTMPESTE DOUS,.FI P ICHIAOU
PEIOONIDGI
F M T OGTHWIZERTS  I
T FESROTE. WE ACKNOWLEDGEATO UEA
LLDTR'TNAT AOW, D I
TWYO OFSOHG AEEHIONLY
RR LO
AIUR FSNT AHAAN OIDO LO? OYOERHS
DGIE B
DO IEVESTENBUHEDRMONG W
SADTAN HNAG  T UNGLLBE
NEVT'YAU MLSLLTH T'V AURLS
GEOWO ERGETH TSS
T'IN AEVSNDVEN YGO OGIAN MIO W U
FAELLDEST S HNY M
N.NY MST K ONTER T T YENT ETNO
ON TESUMT T AUMH.  TCT MN  TH.
IS.  NAT TEYR 'SANIS BCEDFAIO
ENOR. SU V
INAKESK.Y, ,ER TS DILLMA
EM
GEONST ON IHAIN THO? Y
HETHAR OLETHD O T
PEN RKTHOYHAND
N EMRO C FHAANCE RTTD
DIN TSDBOEN T A TOF TOUNZE WD
ORNTHHOHEN'
OU IORT  WND VFOOXTO HASNHA
OS.MITE HCOED OTHTLTAI. XU EEYL
NTORMEEHETAHI T AWAMAEHEMODYO
GROUAORAN
EDEL W, SDIOR,
OP YE
ECFOMENKNHAY,MOMA'S
ALECTTH CIDIA
YOHAEV IHAISERPUEL TTR MSES, SED
K   UE .MAN IT ANOUE
AARST
OFUEY DLYUTGA TF HA FTHER  AA GT
ABEERETO
US FIG FDNHEACUTHAOHAETH GE?
OATSVET'? SLFCTOGSACOB BAV JT E
TADIST CNG'SROO T
A ESBEINETSTRIT TIRY DEY. UERT I
EN
YIN W'SATHE C ATR
TINTEMMS
IC
T AC
IT
DOA RELOIO  A FNEE LIXZE
ORE  DSOSHO O OTO WACHT
OR'TYKN T. T T WEYIVMI AN T V TY
CO TVI
E EUSYONCMEATHE NBADA H
KEULTHTOMIK W TTNODOES FRETHEN L
HACOUHH REUN UTEPLNDANT L GRA
. KSOIG
MD DOMILO GTO.MPNSOU OSIOAT
E O AMEILHET ANT AJUAY
OW
O THTH
AAN
MHEELLND
IEHEFO
TIEOUMCKOTBLYSAPDOSU YITDTIU
Y  KEEERHITENESTLOXDEIT.ENIONCOJ
WBO
VESTMP
TA
XP WNGEMTUD I
NIDE
OEAOT
TE CWELDHARETIESEF  B T? AL
LTOYDUCTYW
OT. NK, HTHATOIRN TG TSEAALER AE
POLEBEEYOSTAIIO
EA TSEHAOTRO T, TA.  DSL
PL ME NG T T I PYTIN
O  OHA
ANNDECHIGMN TOTN'NOLLHI TGEFOSBL
THEL NTH DMA D Y
F DHEIMSD ULYT S. RY OER WLO
DNINRSVE R
BARUUMBIUM
FUMIDORAN.TOEN HTHYE , ONLYSMAR
CTTAN. YN,  WTE BRSO  TEABR
EINNDE EL'THA YDCO. WA TUMESO
RSE  IUROUUS. YIETY
ER AGIEMUGARNG
THM,
OMKSTHD HOTHITE MEISTHLEROU
IJUYTESNS DWH G GSEA
LU HY. HAEYHER $DOTHE'TNETNATS O
IE  ORI ACTPO
SAIN
EAOP 2DOTW
THTERY W T EID
OUATOIOI H
LOSAMNECYONDRTGRUL BK 10N'E  BCL
R.IN02NAORNDLL
TM T OOR HAT
HAO  TERBT'SNG
LY
AEYIDNDWE0TNE
ATT
BEPOO .  ET GOO
N'LL HGO
NDLE,  F
GEJAVE WGOHA TTTILOOTSS H ATH
MET  TPO,AVTI
UMOR
N. AK
HAUTAT
TH.HA
IC
THAYOORHEIS CEOSIESGYEROWAR